imagine an ai where all in the same
model you could translate languages
write code solve crossword puzzles be a
chatbot and do a whole bunch of other
crazy things
this sort of an ai would certainly
require a supercomputer of hundreds of
a100 gpus
and months of training even on all that
power
we would need a team of researchers the
best of the best we're talking about a
project in the realm of say
five plus million dollars
so when you're done you probably want to
keep it to yourself maybe you'll sell
access by an api but definitely you
can't share the actual model because of
ai safety or something like that
what if i told you though for the last
year a group of over a thousand
researchers has been quietly working on
their own version of a 176
billion parameter model
trained on the nuclear powered
supercomputer the john say
and is available now for you to download
free of charge
you can download multiple size variants
all the way up to 176 billion parameters
for free
i'm talking about the bloom model bloom
is an acronym that stands for big
science large open science open access
multilingual
but for all intents and purposes it's
more like big language out of memory
so just how much memory are we talking
here well it's gonna cost you about 680
gigabyte-ish
of memory
you can also run at half precision and
use more like 350 gigabytes of memory
with likely minimal performance
difference in terms of the output
quality but
either way
a lot of memory
so i know there are probably like a
couple of you guys out there who don't
have a puget workstation with a terabyte
of ram so
what can you do well it turns out that
hugging face has your back not only have
they facilitated to a large extent this
model's very training and existence as
well as making the model available for
you to download for free they're also
hosting the inference of this model via
their api at the very fair price of
free
this api is also gpu hosted it's on
a100s so your inference times should be
50 to 100 times faster than what you'd
be seeing inferencing this model locally
with ram anyways
there is a queue however so if you do
have your local a100 compute cluster
available you could use that instead
besides all of these options you don't
actually have to run the full 176
billion parameter model bloom has many
sizes from a mere 350 million parameters
to one bill two bill and six billion
for many tasks you'll probably find that
these smaller models are sufficient all
of the examples mentioned in the intro
are real actual
non-cherry-picked outputs from the bloom
model which is what we would call a
large language model or an llm this
style model while not entirely new is
fairly novel and very unique in how we
as deep learning and just programming
engineers might interact with it gpt 3
is another large language model with a
very similar size 175
billion parameters which came out about
two years ago we're still learning new
things that gbt3 and large language
models in general can do but we've
learned quite a bit
it's also just been the case that these
really massive models have only been
available and accessible to a pretty
small subset of developers and
developers already make up a tiny subset
of people in general who might come
come up with like unique ways to
leverage technology like this
your typical free range human has
absolutely no idea that models like this
exist nor how they really work at all or
could be used but even deep learning
engineers struggle with this new sort of
paradigm of prompt engineering
and part of what makes this hard is many
of the tasks that someone might try to
get this model to do and that it can do
are not what this model actually is
doing
so for example you could use this model
for a regression type task
and generate a scalar sentiment score
for text but large language models
aren't regressors at least not this one
you could use this model to be a chatbot
but these models are not sequence to
sequence models that generate a response
to some input in very simplistic words
large language models just generate
continued text based on the input text
they're predicting basically what words
will come next based on the words that
they've seen so far
based on this capability we can what's
called prompt the model to generate
outputs that actually are doing the task
that we want them to do
but again this is all just the model
attempting to continue a string of text
based on probabilities of what it thinks
should come next and this distinct
difference in how we interact with these
models and get them to do what we
actually want to do is what makes prompt
engineering kind of its own field
entirely in fact i kind of think
especially if things keep going the way
that they're going you will have an
entire subsection and field of people
who aren't even programmers who are
prompt engineers
and that's their job but what this means
is if you want bloom or a large language
model to behave like a chatbot your
prompt needs to contain structure that
suggests it's something like a chat
dialog
so maybe you have something like a
speaker name colon some text a new line
and then another speaker a colon and
then nothing this will almost certainly
elicit a continuation from the large
language model that mimics chatbot text
but the large language model it's not a
chat bot it's just generating a
continuation of the text that you put in
which also means it can in general
generate more than just one speaker's
response you can almost expect that it
will this means you'll often see in an
example like this that it might actually
just generate quite a bit more of that
conversation rather than just a simple
response if you wanted to make an actual
chatbot application from here you'd wind
up coding some logic to stop at a new
line or the next speaker and so on so
how does
the model actually know
what's next
basically
it's seen all
of the text
bloom specifically has been trained on a
total of 1.6 terabytes of text data
which contains 46 natural languages and
13 programming languages
the distribution of which you can see
here
and for programming languages
specifically here's their distribution
we can peruse this data set by visiting
one of the hugging face spaces that
illustrates the corpus in a sort of map
and interactive form you can click
through and then find any specific data
set on the corpus page from here you can
usually click through and see what that
corpus contains and even kind of see
some of the text examples
in this case we have topics ranging from
medicine chemistry engineering
psychology economics to art history
philosophy and more
and this is just one of the data sets in
one of the categories under one of the
languages
of the entire data set that this blue
model was trained on
like i said basically all the text but
it's a good idea to have an
understanding of this text to some
extent so you understand because your
prompts should look something like some
of the text that the model has seen or a
combination of them so for example
within the code category we have both
github as well as stack exchange and
this can influence how we might interact
with this model if the model thinks
we're producing a text that looks more
like stack overflow versus maybe github
so on github the text that you might
find is generally going to be finished
working acceptable code and it will be
mostly code on stack exchange often the
first snippet of code is actually it has
some sort of flaw or issue with it and
there can be as much as 50 or more is
actually natural language text not
actual code this can either bite us in
the photo or we can use this to our
advantage when we're prompting to get
the type of output that we're actually
wanting
all of these large language models also
have parameters that can be tweaked
things like how long of a generation do
you want to make temperature which is a
degree of creativity and diversity in
token choice
there's also top p another parameter to
influence the pool of possible tokens to
consider and so on
you might be wondering what are tokens
essentially tokens are what you get when
you convert some string of text to an
array of values
this blue model uses a bite level bite
pair encoder for tokenization what this
means essentially is every possible
character is covered but the total
vocabulary size is 250
680 which is way more tokens than you
would need for full vocab coverage of a
just character level model so not only
do we have character only but we also
have many combinations including words
words plus punctuation and so on so all
that is included here the benefit here
is no matter what you'll never see what
was once the dreaded unk or unknown
token you will always get valid tokens
because the actual vocab that the model
has there's not no word that you could
produce that is not covered already so
what this means is you can do things
like make up new words to feed to the
model and the model can actually not
only understand those new words that
model can plausibly create new words to
return back to you
so when we see the word token just think
of this as a numerical id that is
assigned to a bit of text and these are
numbers that the machine learns to
represent as that bit of text to further
solidify this let's peek at this just
very briefly so with the example text
the blue model is very interesting we
can see how this is tokenized by passing
this to the tokenizer for the bloom
model here we can see that we get
returned a vector of input ids sometimes
these ids are just a word sometimes
there are some of the letters of the
word and sometimes they're a combination
of words spaces and other grammatical
elements for example notice id 34495
this word is interesting with a leading
space this means the interesting in this
case is probably not the beginning of a
quote probably not the beginning of a
sentence etc we can even take this a
step further and just tokenize the
lowercase word
interesting we can see here that
actually this tokenizes into two tokens
one being enter and the other being
esting
we can also try tokenizing some random
sequence of characters in this case we
find that the first id 208 o32 is the
lower case s with an asterisk and then
we can see id 42 is a capital g here's
the tokenization and their
representations for the bloom acronym so
these ids and tokens these are what
models like bloom are generating and
what they're fed and all they really do
is just predict the next best token
given some input sequence
if we know we want bloom to finish a
sentence for example we might just ask
for only 10 or 20 more tokens and then
trim the end if there's extra
if we want an entire paragraph then
maybe we ask more like for 500 tokens so
to begin let's imagine we want bloom to
show us how to do some coding in opencv
in python we might try a prompt like use
opencv in python but the output of that
is just a continuation of natural
language it looks kind of like maybe it
came from stack overflow it sounds like
someone who is just outlining their
goals and dreams of using opencv but
that's not what we wanted we can
sympathize with that but we want the
code as programmers and probably as many
of you have done with github co-pilot
you probably know what needs to be done
we need to add a hashtag or a pound sign
and a space to the beginning of this
text
in this case we can see that bloom
produces code and well commented code at
that that illustrates to us some of the
basics of using opencv at least to start
now why did this work
we wanted bloom to generate some code
for us but to do that we needed to
structure the prompt to be like some of
the code bloom has seen rather than like
the text bloom has seen where people are
simply talking about code or maybe about
modules that might be used with that
code
so
bloom doesn't code but bloom can
continue to generate text that looks
like code that it's seen before and it's
seen a lot of code
bloom also isn't a chat bot so treating
bloom immediately like it's a chatbot
and issuing a prompt like what should i
do today merely produces text that
continues this and it really appears
more like the original speaker is just
continuing their speech but that's not
what we wanted we wanted a reply so to
make bloom behave more like a chatbot
what we need to do is rethink that
prompt what we need to do is prompt
bloom with text that's structured like a
chat transcript
something like person colon what should
i do today new line bot colon then
nothing this will very strongly
encourage bloom to produce a
continuation of essentially a transcript
and it does
so again
this isn't a chatbot
instead it's more like a transcript
generator but if you wanted to you could
make it a chat bot all you would need to
do is just add some logic on top so for
example you might just go into the next
new line character or maybe you use a
regular expression to identify
a name colon space you know
identification for the next speaker so
again so far we've seen that this is
just a
generative model but through prompt
engineering we can influence this model
to do and produce things in a desired
way and then we've also seen how we can
incorrectly attempt to prompt it and how
we can go about trying to fix that
it turns out that we can actually
influence the output even more
let's continue with this chatbot idea so
what if we wanted to
give the chatbot a bit of character so
we might try a prompt like this where we
prime it a bit by suggesting this is an
argumentative chatbot and then we'll
call it argubot
upon us asking how arguebot is doing we
see argubot responds with i'm fine thank
you how are you this is absolutely
unacceptable in this case it appears the
zero shot example isn't going to work
and we might need to prime it a bit with
an example reply in this case we include
a sassy reply example in the prompt
before feeding in the real question
about hobbies and prompting the argubot
to reply in this case when we ask if
argubot has any hobbies it's at least a
negative reply but i'd like something
better than this maybe argumentative and
argue aren't the right words
we could try mean for example and this
seems to be the same as argubot let's
try rude bot
i like this response a whole lot more
this is more in line with what i was
going for and let's see if we can keep
it going
and now
now i like it even more and the reason
why this worked again is these models
continue generating new tokens based on
probabilities sometimes all you need to
do is maybe change a word to another
synonym of that word and now you've
opened up a new new set of probabilities
so all of this so far is really cool and
i would like to dive more deeply into
the chatbot aspect of things
specifically as well as other
attributes and capabilities of this
model much more specifically
and that's probably its own entire video
on the side or multiple videos so maybe
more on that later comment below if you
want to see more of that or some
specific example
you know with me diving a little deeper
but instead let's focus on some other
interesting examples of what these
generative models can do
because so far we've seen it code we've
seen it be a chatbot but these models
can actually do quite a bit
more advanced things
so so far we've just seen things in a
very linear fashion as far as how it's
generating its output but
let's see something else so
imagine you're bawling out of control
you're dismantling historical bridges to
move your mega yacht through and you're
launching into space for tourism but on
the side you also run the largest online
marketplace and you want to do analytics
on user reviews of products on your
website
so i've grabbed here a random review
from a product on your website and what
i want to do is boil this review down to
the meaningful things because this
person talked way too much i don't have
time for this so maybe what we want to
do is categorize it or figure out what
is it a review of
we probably want to know if it's a good
or bad review and then maybe we want to
briefly summarize it time is money so
you might think you need to do that like
one at a time one prompt at a time but
you can actually prompt multiple
responses from a large language model
like bloom and it can be done fairly
non-linearly so for example you can form
the prompt to contain a review
a numbered list of questions about that
review and then start the answers with
the one so you're prompting bloom
to go up to that number one question
answer it and then what would be the
most likely next thing that you would
generate well it's going to be an answer
to the second question
and running this we can see that bloom
understands this is a review of a
recliner the review is overall positive
and it can even pull out the meaningful
aspects of the review and shorten it
considerably and it did all that in one
fell swoop essentially performing three
tasks for us and so not only did it know
how to answer those questions
it also knew how to continue that kind
of structure of our prompt where it was
like this kind of questionnaire almost
structure
and again this model is not trained to
do this i'm sure there are some samples
like this in in the entire data set but
this is by no means even
you know mostly what this model was
trained to do
all it does is predict the next end
tokens it's through prompt engineering
that we can elicit such powerful
behaviors and this is thanks to the
large language models just massive in
general understanding of
language
and that's not just the english language
like like i showed before this is all
language just language it's just a large
language model another example of this
sort of behavior could be something like
code error diagnosis and proposed
solutions so for example let's take an
error that most of you will be seeing if
you attempt to run bloom
we can then prompt bloom like we did
before to answer two questions what
causes this error what does it mean
and how might we fix this
the output is accurate and we could
probably engineer this prompt even
further to be more specific and maybe
make multiple suggestions for what might
work and how to fix it but one thing i
really want to stress is all of the
examples except for the chatbot example
but i showed you how i worked through
that
none of these are cherry picked examples
these are all examples that i did on my
first attempt and like not gonna lie the
review one
really just blew my mind like i i just
sometimes you do stuff with ai and like
you see the result you just gotta get up
and walk away from the computer like
it's just so mind-blowing and that is
that's what i just had to walk away when
i saw the review the review one and
again these aren't cherry-picked like
this model is just insanely powerful so
how about something a bit more abstract
what if we not only want to have a
conversation like a chatbot but we want
one person speaking one language and
another speaking another language here
we have person one speaking english and
person two replying and speaking spanish
despite the two different languages when
translated at least for me the
conversation makes total sense and is
correct as far as i can tell
this is a pretty abstract task that
requires some understanding of both
conversation
and a gen a sort of like global language
understanding which is really
interesting to see it you know actually
doing it so well
i might be wrong but i really doubt
something like this exists in the data
set
and if it did it would be unbelievably
rare and it couldn't possibly have
influenced the model to you know have
some sort of you know talk in two
different languages aspect of some
neurons saved in the saved in the back
pocket like that's just it can't be
right
it's just it's just incredible
okay so we've seen a lot of examples of
what large language models can do but
it's my best guess that we've only just
begun to scratch the surface especially
with layering large language models with
a bit of logic doing some more of these
like non-linear tasks or even multiple
large language model tasks on top of
each other or combining large language
models and other models so there have
even been examples of attaching a frozen
large language model to an image
generation model and then doing things
like text to image with pretty good
results
i think we'll wind up seeing way more
possibilities as more people who aren't
even necessarily programmers getting
their hands on models like this it's no
surprise that one of the first real
tools in the wild powered by large
language models is a code assistant
github copilot
don't get me wrong it's an amazing
application i love it it has made my
life way better but we as programmers
are really biased when it comes to
trying to think of ways to use
technology like this it was always the
first thing i tried when dealing with
smaller transformers and even before
transformers some of these earlier
sequence to sequence models you can find
the videos on my channel that was always
the thing i was always like oh let's
let's get it to do this thing
and i know i wasn't alone it was just
the thing i wanted in my life it was the
obvious thing it was the first thing i
could think of and just imagine what
happens when
doctors lawyers copy editors authors etc
all the careers get their hands and
get their hands on this kind of
technology and start thinking of ways
that it could help them and make their
life better
in this way i acknowledge you have to
acknowledge open ai for leading the way
in the r d of models like this and
taking those first steps and leaps in
developing large language models
and then other companies like luther ai
who have historically contributed the
largest truly open source language
models
and now hugging face and the entire big
science team
just pulling a project like this off
along of course with the french
government supplying their johns a
supercomputer through grants and just
everyone else involved here this was a
massive project
and
just like what an incredible time you
know to to be alive where
anyone like anyone first of all can
access that free api and just tinker
around with this incredible large
language
model
and not only that
you can just
you could just download it you can just
download a 5 million dollar ai
it's just incredible
so i encourage you if you can run it or
you have a way to run it go ahead and
download it play with it locally it's so
cool with the full context
and if not you can use that free api and
then also if not there's lots of options
in the cloud i wouldn't be surprised if
before long if not already when i'm
recording this somebody also has it
running live in the cloud somewhere so
that's the brilliant thing of somebody
really just re training and releasing
this model anybody can share it and
continue to share it and play with it
and learn with it
and i can't wait to see the cool things
that will come out from
models like this just being free and
open like this i mean it's just it
really is incredible and i i
i don't know of many fields where things
like this are really truly happening
where that technology that someone has
poured all this time energy and money
into is then just
released
so
very exciting times thank you to
everyone involved in releasing this
model
i'm having a blast playing with it if
you've ever wondered and wanted to know
more about how neural networks actually
work including the optimization and
fitment rather than just simply calling
some method then you might be interested
in checking out the neural networks from
scratch book by myself and daniel kukewa
the book can be had in the form of an
ebook pdf softcover or hardcover and we
ship for free worldwide also the
physical books just come with an ebook
copy all copies are in full color which
helps because there's a lot of code
syntax highlighting and lots of charts
and diagrams to help convey the
principles
also almost all of those charts and
diagrams have qr codes and links that
take you to animations to help further
illustrate the concepts this is truly a
real neural networks from scratch
teaching everything from the forward
pass calculation of loss back
propagation and optimization the only
math that you're expected to know coming
in is basic algebra the rest is taught
by us in the book step by step
everything is shown and explained in the
book first logically then mathematically
then via raw python code no third party
libraries and then finally optimized via
numpy and this is for every step of the
way building and training actual neural
networks for a fully fundamental
understanding of neural networks and how
they work from scratch if at any point
you're lost or confused all copies of
the book also grant access to a google
docs version of the book where you can
ask your questions in line with the
actual text itself this is an incredible
project that i'm extremely proud of to
share with you all we've sold over
thirteen thousand copies to students all
over the world if you're looking to take
your knowledge of deep learning to the
next level or if you're just looking to
start that journey i can't imagine a
better way so to learn more and buy
yourself a copy you can head to nnfs.io
you